si a n es igual a n cuadrada menos 10
entre n uno calcula a 4 más a 9 por
supuesto a n lo que hace es definirnos
una sucesión y esta sucesión ya está
definida explícitamente ya ya lo único
que tendríamos que hacer es sustituir
los valores que necesitamos y sumarlos
como nos indica en el problema entonces
tenemos que calcular primero cada uno de
estos por separado quien sería a 4 a 4
simplemente sería en esta expresión que
tenemos sustituir cada vez que veamos
una n ponemos un 4 entonces tendremos 4
al cuadrado menos 10 dividido entre 4
141 muy bien y esto y esto a qué
equivale bueno 4 al cuadrado es 16 menos
entre 41 que son 5 y 16 menos 10 son 6
entre 5 muy bien ahí ya tenemos la
expresión de a 4 quien sería 9
a 9 quienes a 9 veamos otra vez mismo
argumento cada vez que veamos un una n
en esta expresión ponemos un 9 ahora
entonces tenemos 9 al cuadrado
bueno 99 al cuadrado menos 10 entre 9
1 y esto tienes igual bueno 9 al
cuadrado es igual a 81 menos 10 y si eso
lo dividimos entre 91 que son 10 lo que
nos queda son 81 menos 10 son 71 entre
10 y ahora simplemente hay que sumarlos
entonces a 4 más a 9 será 6 quintos
as 71 decimos entonces lo que podemos
hacer es reescribir el primer sumando
como bueno en decimos que esencialmente
son 12 decimos y a esto hay que sumarle
71 decimos 71 decimos y esto a que es
igual bueno tenemos 12 décimos y 71
décimos son 83 décimos y esta es nuestra
respuesta final